كشف وزير خارج البريطاني جيمس كليبرري ان
بلاده قد تفرض المزيد من العقوبات على
النظام الايراني وذلك على خلفيه التهديدات
تعرض لها صحفي دون مزدوج الجنسيه في
بريطانيا واكدت ليفر لانه من غير المجد
الكشف عن العقوبات مسبقا مشددا في الوقت
ذاته على ان بلاده وعزيمه على ضمان عدم
ترهيب اي مواطن بريطاني من قبل النظام
الايراني خصوصا الصحفيون الذين يصلون
الضوء على ما يجري في ايران وان بريطانيا
ستقف امام اي تدخلات خارجيه
المشاهدين تسعى الولايات المتحده من خلال
جلسه المجلس الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
التابعي الامم المتحده لاستبعاد ايران من
هيئه المراه المعنيه بالمساوا بين
المسلمين وتمكين المراه وكل ما تحتاجه عند
التصويت على مشروع قرارها لترضيعها من
عضويه هيئه وضع المراه هو الاغلبيه
البسيطه داخل المجلس المكون من اربعه
وخمسين حيث ان كثيرا من الاعضاء غير
مرتاحين لهذا الط قيل المسبوق لدوله عضو
في هيئه وضع المراه بالاضافه الى الامم
المتحده التي التزمت الصمت حول التحرك
الامريكي الاخير لكن يرى المراقبون بان
الولايات المتحده لديها عدد كاف من
الاصوات لتحقيق ما تريد